6 years ago when my older daughter was
13 I bought her a
vibrator I'm done
okay it wasn't something I planned on
doing I mean I knew eventually my
daughters would need bras and tampons
maybe BRAC but a vibrator was not on the
list so why did I do
it before I explain why I want to
acknowledge that I might have made some
of you a little uncomfortable or a lot
uncomfortable so before I explain why I
want to ask you a
question why are we more comfortable
talking about female
pain things like period cramps breast
cancer birthing pains miscarriages and
sexual
assault then we are talking about female
pleasure why does a vibrator make us
uncomfortable but Viagra does
not getting my daughter a vibrator
started me on a journey of thinking
about the importance of empowering
teenage girls helping them to learn
about their bodies and gain a sense of
ownership of their bodies including
embracing their right to
pleasure this is one reason that my own
daughters encouraged me to include their
stories in this talk so I'm going to
talk to you today about sex specifically
in regards to our teenage
daughters I know we don't like to think
about our teenagers having sex and
because of societal double standards
especially our
girls but here's why we need to have
this conversation as uncomfortable as it
may make
us girls typically develop a desire for
sexual contact between the ages of 11
and
14 between the ages of 15 and 19 42% of
them have had vaginal Andor oral
sex through the cell phones right in
their back pockets 57% of girls and 84%
of boys between the ages of 14 and 18
have watched pornography through PornHub
and hundreds of similar
sites so if you have a kid in high
school it isn't a question of if they'll
watch porn before they graduate but more
likely
when this means that a lot of our kids
are getting their sex education and
trying to figure out what's normal from
pornography to illustrate why we can't
leave our kids alone to navigate the
sexual terrain I want to share a story
with
you several years ago I worked with an
incredibly intelligent 14-year-old girl
helping her manage her overall life
stressors during one session she asked
if she could ask me a question about
sex she said that she was confused about
the bases and wondered if it was really
true that second base was anal
sex I was as shocked as you are and yes
when I asked her she did know what anal
sex is she had gotten her information
from watching a few porn clips her
friends had showed her during study hall
at
school thankfully because of the
trusting relationship she had with me
she was able to have this misconception
corrected and her anxiety about it
relieved with her permission I was also
able to Loop her mom in on the
conversation so she could be a resource
for her
daughter
I've worked hard to cultivate this type
of relationship with my own
daughters so when my 13-year-old said
Mom can I ask you a
question kids speak for be prepared for
anything I
listened which is why sitting at a
stoplight on a summer morning my
daughter felt comfortable telling me she
had started to
masturbate and was even willing to share
with me what she was using to do
so this is how I learned that she was
masturbating in a way that was not safe
for her
body and so in the span of one red light
I decided to buy my daughter a
vibrator I wanted to support her in the
safe exploration of a body instead of
Burying my head in the sand which is so
tempting to do as parents with things
that make us
uncomfortable when it comes to sex we
all need to become trusted resources for
our
kids they need to be comfortable coming
to us with questions and know they will
get straight
answers and while this is certainly true
in regards to accurate
information sometimes it's also about
giving them the appropriate
tool when we talk about girls knowing
and exploring their bodies it's easy to
get
uncomfortable but girls becoming
familiar with their bodies is a about
health masturbation helps girls reduce
stress ease headaches and alleviate
cramps associated with their
periods when girls explore their bodies
they learn how their bodies feel when
they are healthy which also helps them
recognize changes and potential
problems they have to touch their bodies
to know their
bodies this became clear to me when I
was working with one of my adult clients
after Her diagnosis was stage four
breast
cancer as we discussed her prognosis she
said to me Robin if I'd only done my
breast checks maybe I would have caught
it
sooner maybe I wouldn't be
dying but my client had been raised
believing that touching herself was
inappropriate on the few occasions she
did a breast check she didn't know what
was typical and she rushed through them
feeling
embarrassed when girls are comfortable
touching their bodies whether for self-
brush checks or for pleasure they learn
about their
bodies and when they know their bodies
they can better own their bodies this is
important when it comes to sex too often
others are dictating what girls should
expect want and put up with these
expectations are being set by
pornography social media politicians and
Partners who are either much more
experienced or equally
inexperienced I mean let's face it what
does the average teenage boy know about
the female clitoris or the female
[Music]
orgasm given the statistics that about
15% of women have never had an orgasm
and 81% of women do not orgasm through
vaginal sex it is important for our
girls to know that it's okay to figure
out what gives them
pleasure and that they don't have to
rely on someone else for that
pleasure this can help them make choices
which benefit them as an example another
one of my clients share with me that she
uses her vibrator before she goes on any
date this way she can make judgments
about the date based on the person and
their connection rather than on
hormones and then when our daughters do
decide to have sex with someone else
they will know enough about their sexual
pleasure to be able to communicate what
feels good to their
Partners they won't have to follow the
outdated Norms of tolerating
unsatisfying experiences faking it or
even believing that their sole purpose
is to serve someone else's
pleasure our daughters will get the
message that their wants and needs are
important learning not to be ashamed of
their sexual pleasure is not limited to
girls and young women I worked with a
65-year-old woman who had never ever had
an
orgasm she came to me for coaching
because she felt
demoralized she had recently retired
from her vice president position feeling
pushed out by our company as they hired
younger
Executives she had two goals for
coaching the first was to find new ways
to spend her time which gave her
purpose the second one was and I quote
to try out an
orgasm when she was ready my client
bought herself a vibrator and began
learning about her body for the first
time in her life
I will never forget the day when she
came to our session sat down demurely
and said with a big beautiful grin
second goal
[Applause]
[Music]
achieved as she continued to learn about
herself and her sexual pleasure my
client stopped referring to herself as
old she accepted a board position for a
national
nonprofit she even created a profile in
E
Harmony can I say it was simply due to
the
orgasm of course not but in asking for
more from this one area of her life she
realized she could do the same in other
areas of her
life we can help our daughters adopt
this perspective long before my client
did we can support their healthy sexual
development but even even
more by doing so we Empower their entire
sense of
selves this is about helping our girls
step into their power raising them to
become strong women who can speak up for
themselves whether they are in the
bedroom or in the
boardroom recently my younger daughter
reminded me of just how well she can
speak up for herself
a few months ago she was out with
friends and called to let me know when
she'd be home she's good like that as we
were wrapping up the conversation she
said oh by the way Mom my vibrator broke
can you pick me up a new
one later on she told me that after she
hung up her friend said I can't believe
your mom bought you a
vibrator to which my daughter
responded I can't believe your moms
haven't
thank
you